hey guys speed here it's going to be
another game of Thrones
seven episode four preview I got a
couple death threats in comments
yesterday about the title of my video
which was pretty silly when you think
about it because HBO released photos
like they do every week and they show
Theon coming ashore in the upcoming
episode and it's clearly at Dragonstone
so yeah the internet is a strange place
but as I mentioned they did put out some
new photos and I thought it was
interesting because of the way this game
were kind of composed and we got these
three of Winterfell but rather being a
photo of say Arya standing in the yard
or something like that we see that we
have two pictures in particular one of
Littlefinger looking down and the other
one of POD and Brienne and I think the
one of Todd and Brienne especially
they're looking at something the look on
their face is that the somewhat contains
excitement I thought when I saw it at
first and then we also see this shot of
Santa who is by the heart tree and hers
is a little bit different so anyways
what I had thought originally when I saw
these photos was that we had seen Aria
outside of Winterfell in the trailer
which I talked about in my trailer
breakdown but we don't see her in any of
these and obviously this is a big thing
her coming home right so my guess is is
that these people all of the photos of
people at Winterfell relate directly to
Arya's return I certainly could be wrong
but the other big thing going on in
Winterfell is brand came back last
episode and since he can't walk around I
feel like it's a pretty good guess there
is one thing that we know for sure and
that is that this is the shortest
episode of the season it's only 50
minutes long so once we hit like the 25
minute mark here we are officially
halfway through the season as far as the
episodes go obviously the last two are
longer but 50 minutes is short this is
like 9 minutes shorter than the other
episodes and just to put that into
perspective from the
I'm that we see grey worm getting ready
to enter the tunnel at Casterly Rock in
the last episode until the time that
Elena finishes her speech and the
credits start to roll that's less than
eight minutes for all of that stuff to
happen so this will be a noticeably
shorter episode I don't think that's
going to affect too much here but it
will in the other video that I'll be
doing on Saturday probably I have an
idea about that
either way we got new photos of
Winterfell Aria is not in any of them
but I do believe that she will return we
don't have enough time for much games as
far as that's concerned and I kind of
have an idea that all of these are these
theories out there about her wearing
another face they're doing all this
nonsense to drag things out will prove
to be untrue because like I said we
don't have much time and there was this
bit of foreshadowing where we saw
Littlefinger unsheathing the cat's paw
dagger or the cat's paw blade in the
trailer then this has sparked a lot of
theory and speculation especially about
him possibly trying to murder Brant I
was sort of thinking about this all
morning and it's sort of a knee-jerk
reaction that's the simplest explanation
he's pulling a knife out because he's
going to go kill Brant why does he want
to kill bran well because bran is
extremely powerful and he can see how
things truly are rather than the way
Petyr Baelish once Santa and the other
people werner fell to see them in short
he could expose him for all his
treachery without a doubt i have a big
problem with this idea though because
one it's very unlit affinor as I guess
you would say that he would just go
around stabbing people he usually has
other people that he relies on and uses
if you think about it the reason we
refer to this blade as the cat's paw
blade is because it was originally used
in the attempt on brands like way back
in season 1 the assassin was a cat's paw
had this knife by definition the word
cat's paw means someone
who's like a dupe or someone who's used
for someone else's means as a tool
basically so a hired gun in this case
would be a cat's paw he has no reason
himself for wanting brand dead but he'll
do it for the money of course back then
it was a totally different story though
because bran was protected by summer and
he had his mom watching him of course
and nowadays we don't really know but it
seems like it wouldn't be impossible for
bailiffs to just go in there and stab
him and they've certainly been
foreshadowing this blade we saw it on
our is hit on the cover of that magazine
we saw it in the illustration in Sam's
restricted books and then we saw it in
this trailer but if you think about the
original scenario some people believe
that Littlefinger was behind that I
don't necessarily think that but it's
not even important here the important
part of that whole scenario is what he
did once he had that information he
turned it on tearing he made up the
story that he lost it in a bet and that
basically started the war of the five
kings so that's how Littlefinger
operates he injected chaos into a
situation because it was good for him
now we have brand returning he's already
there and Arya is coming in as well
outside of her brother's supernatural
capabilities
Arya's flat-out seen Baelish doing some
things in the past when she was working
for Tywin when no one exactly knew who
she was she witnessed it you know his
dealings firsthand so she is also a
potential threat I don't really think
it's likely that he could kill her
either though I mean if you think about
these two scenarios let's look at them
in the overall scheme of thing on the
one hand he could kill brand and brand
brand is basically defenseless and the
guy is cunning his little finger could
definitely figure out a way to get
himself alone in there
and slit his throat but how on earth
would he get away with it
what is the situation that he could
create in order to make himself not look
guilty there it's a stretch Ari on the
other hand is more than capable of
defending herself so he doesn't really
have a chance if he wanted her I mean
yeah he could try to get her in her
sleep but I don't know if she's on some
other level stuff now so I just don't
think that that's very likely so what is
actually going on with this blazing
after mulling it over since this
trailers come out I'm kind of thinking
that that whole scene of showing it was
a red herring at least as painting it as
an implement of destruction I mean just
being a possession of it is not really
that great for a little finger but
that's easy enough to explain away there
are a lot of theories out there that are
saying that he's going to do this
because it goes against his nature
that's going to somehow be his demise
but I'm not 100% sure because I don't
think we've seen the last of
Littlefinger yet we're really believing
that his path and this whole series was
to make it all the way to this part and
then just screw up by doing something
impulsive I think instead what we're
looking at is we're looking at a
situation where there's a lot of people
around who could expose him for what he
is
so in Littlefinger's methodology
wouldn't it make a whole lot more sense
that he's going to try to turn things
around and try to discredit arya and
bran in some way I mean I really don't
know I'm not going to sit here and tell
you that I know what's going to happen
I'm just saying me be a little skeptical
of these theories that are saying that
it all it's going to go down this way
because we really don't know and don't
sell Littlefinger short I think that's
the moral of the story I do think he's
on his way down I mean that he's just in
a bad setup but I would be really kind
of surprised I guess if that that was
how he ultimately was destroyed was just
by making a quick mistake I feel like
he's going to go out in a blaze of glory
but I could be wrong so let me know what
you guys think I've heard that there's
some Aria stuff out there so please
don't spoil people's experience of this
next episode
posting in the comment I heard there was
a leak and there's lots of articles
about that so I'm sure there's probably
stuff out there I don't go looking for
leaked stuff so please don't post it
here I erased the comment earlier on one
of my other videos that was a little
borderline for my case though just just
be you know you can do whatever you want
just don't ruin it for other people but
yeah let you know let me know what you
guys think in the comments please like
this video make sure you subscribe and
definitely yeah if you subscribe
nowadays you have to also hit that
little bell below for notifications and
I'd appreciate both make sure you follow
me over on Twitter and my facebook page
and Instagram accounts I got a couple
more videos in the works before episode
4 comes out - make sure you check back
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon
[Music]
you
you
you
you